[Musique]
il est têtu surprenant bonjour alexandre
l'euro ancien service civique de la
coopération internationale et régionale
vous en prie bienvenue chez moi mon lien
avec madagascar
eh bien je me suis construit dans mon
enfance autour de madagascar puisque
nous en parlions énormément au sein de
la famille il m'a aussi en dehors
avec la vie de l'association vous
présente mon père jean-marc si j'ai
choisi cette ce contrat c'est en partie
à cause de lui ça c'est la photo
d'alexandre qui pour la remise des prix
la première année de l'école de
l'association dans les locaux de l'école
l'a3 qu'il a
la main sur le coeur et il aime bien
tout ce qui est tout ce qui est à alger
ou autre il a envie d'aider il fait
partie la croix rouge il partir et bien
c'est quelque chose d'assez radical
puisque nous allons perdre tous nos
repères toutes nos habitudes tout notre
confort c'est qui nous permet justement
que quand on revient ou de mieux
apprécier ce que nous avons il était en
bas que je crois en bac pro à l'époque
et on a rencontré une dame qui
travaillait au département pour les
laits service civique qu'il en a parlé
comme ça et je salue rentrée l'oreille
et s'est lui rester dans la tête
nous sommes au lycée agricole émile
boyer de la giroday j'y ai passé deux
ans pour mon bts dark dark ce
développement agricole en régions
chaudes
il ya beaucoup de mobilité dans cette
formation puisque nous avons fait trois
en l'espace de deux ans le premier qui
était pour le salon culture à paris le
second en afrique du sud pour la
création d'un jardin potager et le
troisième à madagascar pour faire une
analyse régionale depuis très longtemps
les postes de vsc qui sont proposés par
le département en lien avec
l'agriculture sont proposées très
régulièrement à nos étudiants puisque en
général ils se sont vendus dans le cadre
de leurs études sur un de ces lieux de
débauche que ce soit à maurice ou à
madagascar et parce que leur formation
en particulier donc celle suivie par
alexandre développement de l'agriculture
des régions chaudes et tout à fait
opérationnel sur ce type de poste
[Musique]
la première arrivée à anti rabais a été
surprenante puisque ça m'a changé de
mode de vie les commissions devient
madagascar était très bonne puisque
j'avais une maison mise à disposition
avec beaucoup du confort moderne n'est
pas tous malheureusement certaines
choses basiques pour nous ici ne sont
pas disponibles là bas bien madagascar
est un pays qui grandit les apporte
unités sont innombrables
ce que j'aimerais que les gens
retiennent c'est que c'est une
expérience qui va changer votre vie ne
serait ce que par le regard que vous
avez sur les autres personnes mais aussi
sur le regard que vous avez de vous même
et puis il n'y a rien de mieux que de
partir premier revenir
nous sommes ici parce que c'est
l'entreprise qui me prend en alternance
pour la licence en agronomie ceux qui on
vienne toujours avec une ouverture
d'esprit encore supérieur et ça veut
dire que derrière dans leur tempérament
ou leur façon de fonctionner il ya
forcément quelque chose de positif et de
dynamique dans ma mission c'est par
rapport aux défis et responsable donc je
m'assure que chaque étape du processus
soit effectuée et complété j'ai dit ça y
est on a un bon triptyque à pouvoir
mettre en place avec alexandre et qu'il
fasse le lien avec nos différents
services
il n'est pas du tout impossible qu'ils
puissent rebondir encore chez nous au
bout d'une année et ça je pense que sans
promesse c'est quelque chose qui serait
tout à fait possible pour les personnes
qui sont intéressées par ce programme
est bien à l'isie puisque ce programme
non seulement va vous redéfinir mais
aussi vous permettre de vous découvrir
par vous même
[Musique]